let's go
they say knowledge is power but what do
you do with it
that's what's important
the apex games are what the champions
are crowned
but the arenas are where legends are
made
i said danger close once you listen
the arenas are my games they're not
about fame
or spectacle they are about the fight
arcstar the rules are simple
it's just your squad and their squad
whoever survives wins
now pay attention this is how the game
is played
assemble your squad in the customary
fashion
before the fight begins squads are
enclosed in their spawn room and have
access to the shop
here you can purchase weapons items and
abilities with crafting materials
i will grant you a set amount of
materials at the start of each round
you may earn more through your
performance
materials can be used immediately or
saved for superior equipment later in
the match
no purchased gear follows between rounds
wait where's all my stuff materials can
be used to upgrade weapons
making you an even greater threat
at the end of the buy phase the shields
drop and the fun begins
both teams engage in combat until one
side is wiped out
downed teammates can still be revived
but in this game there are no respawns
use the pressure it's the only way to
survive
supply bins containing consumables and
material canisters are scattered
throughout the arena
a single air drop containing three
weapons arrives in the middle of each
round
the tier of the weapons in the drop pod
increases from round to round
use them to overpower your competition
it's high risk
high reward maybe next time you should
try a different path
the first team to score three victories
with a two-win margin will be declared
the champion if teams battle to a
deadlock 4-4
tie round nine is my favorite part
sudden death tossing up some amped cover
knock down more than a few
each arena has its own personality and
acts as an optimal combat testing ground
the phase runner on olympus wasn't the
first of its kind
a prototype long abandoned rests in a
remote section of talos
luckily it remains intact and functional
providing unique combat opportunities to
those clever enough to seize them
there's a research of it and then of
course uh
coma was simply another outlands hotspot
turned yesterday's news
until an ill-fated joyride gave it a new
landmark
you're welcome with my assistance
the city has been reignited with a new
monument to incompetence
thank you for this i feel much better
about myself now
i have also secured some viable
locations throughout the outlands
to serve as arenas
and don't get too comfortable the future
promises to be a bit
fiery
oh yes a new legend has joined the fight
this little one and i share a common
legacy pilot blood runs through her
veins
this is valkyrie
she is as fearless as she is reckless
friend or foe make sure you look up as
she takes the fight to the skies
your journey is here legends this guy's
belong to me now
the arenas are the ultimate test of
skill and resolve
so i have a gift the bow check
compound bow
this precision weapon requires patience
and pinpoint consistency
it is made even deadlier with its two
hop-up slots
legends can combine shatter caps
splitting the arrow tip into a shotgun
pattern
and dead eyes tempo allowing a faster
draw when firing at the optimal pace
master all of this and you will become a
true
assassin you gotta take risks to be
champ
the need to prove superiority is
instinctive
hopefully you can impress me
i'll see you in the arenas olympus
security
perimeter alert multiple unknown ships
entering secure space all personnel
please secure docking stations and
prepare for arrival
security forces on full alert
[Music]
things are about to get mighty
interesting
[Music]
you